huddled frightened and packed into
border force boats more than a hundred
migrants made it across the channel
today and that comes after 254 people
across the channel on sunday according
to the ministry of defense's latest
figures in just seven boats
it gives you an idea of just how
dangerously overcrowded those small
dinghies are
but they keep on coming it's expected
that the number of migrants intercepted
in the english channel today will
surpass the 254 of yesterday
it's not just young men who the
government say make the crossing is
economic migrants some are very frail
and need to be helped by border force
guards and children and babies are among
those on the boats
it's warm here in dover the sea behind
me is flat and calm ideal conditions you
might think for a bank holiday crossing
if you were on a ferry or a yacht
however in small flimsy boats it's still
incredibly dangerous but that's not
enough to put some people off making the
treacherous crossing
nor is the government's nationality and
borders bill which became law on
thursday and makes it a criminal offence
to knowingly arrive in the uk illegally
the government hopes that in a matter of
weeks it will be able to send migrants
like these to rwanda to apply for asylum
in that country the policy was supposed
to be deterrent for those risking the
journey
critics say the reality is the
government hasn't given people
alternative routes leaving them
vulnerable to exploitation it's a cruel
inhumane approach to expel people to
rwanda to treat them as nothing more
than human
cargo they have no choice people that
are trying to reach the uk they have
other no other safe route to get to the
uk if you're fleeing the taliban what
are you supposed to do a government
spokesperson said over the weekend the
rise in dangerous channel crossings is
unacceptable
not only are they an overt abuse of our
immigration laws but they also impact on
the uk taxpayer risk lives and our
ability to help refugees come to the uk
by safe and legal routes
there has been increased surveillance in
the channel there have been drones as
well as royal navy patrols
but there's still a lack of cooperation
and disagreement between the french and
british border forces and caught in the
middle prayed on by smugglers are the
desperate people with no other options
madeleine ratcliffe sky news in dover